serge gainsbourg sort un nouveau disque
dix chansons agressive contre la femme
mais avec le ton d'un homme qui frappé
d'une crise cardiaque il ya quelques
mois prend du recul va à l'essentiel est
fait de sa misogynie plus une attitude
de créer qu'un véritable règlement de
comptes vu de l'extérieur
et là je connais tout ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur
j'avais quelques amis jeunes en rien un
peu moins jeunes est plus difficile plus
sauvage
de plus en plus misanthrope
j'étais déjà misogyne je te fais la mise
en tofu verrez pas grand chose mais il
reste des choses essentielles les
enfants enfin et la création continue
avec l'esprit plus lucides et les mains
qui ne tremble plus enfin presque
je suis venu te dire que je m'en
et dans les pouilles
pour rien changé
comme dit ci vient de rennes pouvant
mauvais
je suis venu te dire
tu te souviens des jouets anciens
tu blagues
je suppose que tu voulais
devant
ce qu'un cheveu
des adieux à jamais
je suis heureux
se dire je m'en veux et l'apport
l'apport de l'alcool et du tabac sur
l'intellect
pour moi c'était très nocif changé
j'étais tellement saturé que je restais
les nuits entières sans rien trouver
j'allais assez vite donc j'ai vu
beaucoup de paysages des filets mais
j'ai coché un du platane
normalement je sais que je suis
légèrement blessés au coeur va accepter
j'espère que ce pari mais là je pouvais
je monde
tous
cette agressivité mon moteur ceci non la
bataille et qui écrivent bien écriture
le professeur de lycée moi j'aime casser
des plumes et faire des pâtés tous deux
tons poster au vu de l'extrême
bon j'avais un jeu bien
ce sont pour mettre un peu plus depuis
il est en stéréo